لا يمكن تقييم حجم الضرر جراء استهداف سدك
خفك بالكامل الا في الايام المقبله لكن
عواقب الضربه خطيره وبعيده المدى على
جانبي الجبهه هذا ما خلصت اليه الامم
المتحده بعد الضربه فما هي اخطر التداعيات
احدث التفجير فيضانات غمرت اكثر من عشرين
منطقه ماهوله ما تطلب اجلاء الاف الاشخاص
وزاره الزراعه الاوكرانيه تقول ان قرابه
عشره الاف هكتار من الاراضي الزراعيه في
منطقه خرسون والمناطق الجنوبيه من النهر
ستغمرها المياه الضرر طال ايضا محطه
كخوفكا الكهرومائيه ما يعني ان اربعه
وتسعين في المئه من انظمه الري في منطقه
خيرسون واربعه وسبعين في المئه فيزا
بروجيا وثلاثين في المئه
دون مصادر ترفضها بالمياه ومن ثم قد تتحول
حقول جنوب اوكرانيا الى صحاري بحلول العام
المقبل بحسب وزاره الزراعه الاوكرانيه
وتعتبر هذه الحقول من اكثر الاراضي خصوبه
في البلاد ترفد السله الغذائيه العالميه
وكانت ترتوي من بحيره سدك خوفكا احد اكبر
السدود في اوروبا
ويحذر خبراء ايضا من ان البحر الاسود
بدوره قد يتاثر نتيجه تدفق كميات كبيره من
المياه العذبه وتداعياتها على الثروه
السمكيه اما عسكريا وبينما يستمر تراشق
الاتهامات بالضلوع في الاستهداف تقول
اوكرانيا ان تفجير السد سيعرقل خططها
بهجوم مضاد لا سيما ان تقدم لقواتها
باتجاه المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في
خرسون
ويشير محللون عسكريون الى ان اغراق
المناطق المحيطه بالنهر سيؤدي الى تشكل
مستنقعات تعرقل حركه الاليات المدرعه
الداعمه لقوات المشاه كالدبابات والمصفحات
وسيترتب على ذلك تاخير اي هجوم اوكراني
محتمل لمده شهر على الاقل ورغم ان
اوكرانيا لم تحدد تماما محاور الهجوم
المضاد الا ان خبراء رجحوا ان تدفع كييف
بقواتها عبر محوري زابوروجيا وخيرسون
لتطويق القوات الروسيه المتمركزه في
المنطقتين وفصل هذه الوحدات الروسيه
جغرافيا عن تلك المتمركزه في شبه جزيره
القرم
[موسيقى]